I mean there's lots of a diner in the
question and you're at that wonderful
spot right now where there are two
problems that you encounter number one
you don't know which pieces of data are
important to you right because there's
lots of things that you like which do i
use and number two the bits that are
important you're not sure how to combine
them yet right so at the moment maybe
you're just kind of firing off in random
directions yo really what to get here I
don't Uplus while it's got to pop out
the other end I'm kind of doing the
sleep green guardian okay now it should
make you very suspicious that there are
no n terms in the result that you have
to prove right about this possible color
combination see what that suggests to
you is that this is independent of n
that make sense like in in in projectile
motion would be talking about oh yeah
look there's a theta that appears at an
R and V etc well okay then the angle
that you fire out and how far you throw
the ball etc they're all important but
there's no end there then maybe it
doesn't matter how many exactly
identical balls there are all that
really matters is how many you choose
selection of our borders men from the
box and that seems to be all the banners
okay it is all that matters because if
you have a look at that inequality
that's given to you did you notice
there's a domain restriction there what
does that mean can someone interpret for
me what that means they have to n balls
of two different colors and have any
each but then what you're picking from
the set is less than just one Center for
yep yep I think I think I know Jeanette
but it was a bit difficult okay it's a
bit difficult to get across right now
I'm interested I saw very few I saw up
some but I saw very few drawings around
right one of the sick of you saying this
yet one of the classic problem-solving
techniques when you meet something which
is all abstract and ah xk whatever is
make it not abstract put something
concrete on it and then see what's going
wrong right so for instance if there
were three red and three blue here my
identical
shoot choices to vapor oh right it says
zero is less than or equal to our SSN it
um so how many balls could I be choosing
out of this I could be choosing to what
other members could I be choosing look I
has a range I could be choosing one or
three or include be choosing that look 0
is included right all they mean is that
if you choose 0 or 1 or 2 or 3 you could
choose all of one color or all of the
other color or some combination does
that make sense so therefore we don't
care if if all I'm choosy is 0 1 2 or 3
I don't care if there are three red in
three blue or 300 red and 300 blue
doesn't matter all of the options are
possible they could all be blue or be
red or some beans okay all right now
let's think about this right I'm gonna
jot down and yes I had to use words
right I'm gonna shut down the things I
noticed about the question and they will
inform the way that I go through this
okay so here's the first thing I notice
only two colors only two colors hmm
being think when you've been doing
arrangements when you see that there are
only two options too strong what does
that signal to you in terms of all of
the things you know probability binomial
okay you look I'll okay all right so the
client know the pieces are fitting
together right so that's good what else
do I know in the question what well
obvious facts under okay their
independence as you choose each one
there's no you know string of
probabilities that keeps on changing
their independent right and also while
I'm at it right not only are they in the
player from each other but even together
but what doesn't know right what it
doesn't matter
okay they're independent order doesn't
matter so I've already ruled out for
instance it's not like any NPR business
or any factorial business they're all
about where order whether your
arrangement is critical okay I also
noticed within the colors they're
identical so that means for this part of
the question at least NCR's not going to
be much used to me right NCR is not
going to be much used to me because this
is about what i can tell the difference
in this one in this one in this one
right it's like well if they're
identical then you're always going to be
over counting and you don't know how
many of accounting by because you don't
know if you end up picking like you know
to blue and one red or three red like
how many repetitions about over can buy
and you drove the door so that's
important to me okay what else have I
got if I put all these together right
when I say color combinations let's go
in on let's go with this over here
suppose you had to pick three right can
someone give me some color combinations
someone give me my fruit loopy see
you're drunk blue red red okay let's go
with that you're almost routine yourself
and someone give me another one red
blue-blue ok red blue blue so would give
me another round
red blue red okay now I have red blue
red I think I already have red blue red
on the board now because order doesn't
matter yeah I can t how about more blue
or blue I can read or all right okay
have I missed any options now as the
question predicted my value of r was 3
and there are how many color
combinations there are r plus 14 right
so at least the hypothesis works that's
really now look what's the difference
between each of these remember what it
doesn't matter right the difference
between each of these is just how many
colors do you have of each how many
colors you have a metronome is that now
because you've got a fixed number like
ah this is how many ppl if for instance
you know there's going to be one blue
one out of your arm balzer you picked up
you already know how many Red Bulls
they're armed life once you know there's
one blue one there have to be two red
ones because there are only two colors
to choose from does that make sense I in
the same way if I know that there are
two blue ones I don't worry red ones if
I know there are three or if I know
there are 0 knowing how many there are
of one color that quantity tells you how
many you've got on the other quantity
does that make sense so in fact number
one I notice order doesn't matter number
two even both colors don't matter I
really only need to know one of the
colors 0 1 2 3 blue okay haha and you
thought i was just riding a big random
order of the board so all I'm keeping
track off to work out different color
combinations is how many have you got of
each color that's it okay so now here
comes my utter where am I never feel
like it
okay this is public if I choose and yeah
well now you know like water sand right
if I choose ah balls right then the
different color combinations will have
okay now remember right let's just think
our blue for that like you know if we
just think about the blue ones i'm just
going to keep track of how many blue
ones there are in my combination right
there could be zero or one or two or
three what's the maximum number of blue
that i can have our I chosen are right
this is one particular example where r
is three the r could be anything i could
be three hundred three billion bucks so
if i choose are the different color
combinations will have zero one or two
or three or 0 blue it's gonna be one of
these right well how many are there for
there are 0 plus 1 something ok now this
answer is sufficient you like Oh what
was that that's it four percent that's
right okay no kids who had a really
interesting solution right which in its
in the form that i saw it was not enough
was no no but
take a too excited but it actually
yields are very useful insight into this
because remember this is this is behind
a mule after all right how would I write
this what this look like as if I do yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's like well I mean I I
could you know they're independent right
but I don't know if there's a
replacement that kind of thing I'm just
going to say it's either red or it's
going to be blue sorry bro calm or it's
gonna be blue right it's one of the
other one of the other and I have to add
these because if you have the total
right you're getting I wanna be on so
total one how many times don't do this
again ah now each one of the terms that
I get out of this expansion right what
his terms going to look like well the
first one is going to be our numbers are
to the art and then b to the 0 right and
then there will be some number of ours
and then a number of these and then
other than ours and another and then all
the way at the end there will be no no I
left them to speeds right so this
sequence here this some right it
represents all the different choices
right and there are because of Pascal's
triangle r plus 1 times in the expansion
okay right so therefore this kind of an
wats for you what's going on
mathematically but you do need to
justify in some way to the situation
it's not enough just to write that
binomial beach [ __ ] okay okay are you
with me yes okay Mashti really I bet
part two is much easier cartoon have a
look another box contains n white balls
labeled consecutively from one end aha
they're not identical anymore they're
not identified until these apart that's
good a selection of n minus R balls is
made from the box where 0 is less today
who are less negative explain the way
the number of different selections is
NCR okay now this is actually like it's
only one mark and the statesville ones
on this was much better thirteen percent
ah
so we should be our colleges right okay
now think this is much simpler okay then
not identical I have your end true
strong that's how many there are right
yeah that's how many there are and how
many do I have to pick from dad okay so
all I have to do is say this is how many
ways there are now it is a show
questions I've got to go ahead with it
right this is going to be if you recall
that M C k for instance is n factorial
on what again nothing k factorial and
minus K factor it okay so let's just fit
in here on the top you still got that as
your numerator what are the denominator
and my ok there's the K factorial and
then here you've got n minus that right
so that's n minus there's my thing which
is often right which of course you can
see that's n minus N and this appeal
double negative on the arm so that's why
this becomes r factorial and that is the
end saying are they ask for your
different